Is she turning towards you or away from you?
No one can agree.
She's the mysterious subject of Dutch master Johannes Vermeer's...
..."Girl With a Pearl Earring,"...
...a painting often referred to as the "Mona Lisa of the North."
Belonging to a Dutch style of idealized,...
...sometimes overly expressive paintings known as "tronies,"...
...the "Girl With a Pearl Earring" has the allure and subtlety...
...characteristic of Vermeer's work.
Vermeer's treatment of light and shadow or "chiaroscuro"...
...uses a dark, flat background to further spotlight her three-dimensionality.
Instead of being like a set piece in a theatrical narrative scene,...
...she becomes a psychological subject.
Her eye contact and slightly parted lips, as if she is about to say something,...
...draw us into her gaze.
While we may never know the real identity of the "Girl With a Pearl Earring,"...
...we can engage with her portrait in a way that is unforgettable.
As she hangs in her permanent home in the Mauritshuis Museum in The Hague,...
...her presence is simultaneously penetrating and subtle.